foreign
[Music]
a new week a brand new news video check
out the biggest news about your favorite
movies and Series this time you can look
forward to seeing the first images of
Avatar 3 as well as a new Game of
Thrones series and the fifth installment
of the Shrek franchise there is also
information on a Harry Potter series a
new Street Fighter movie and the
live-action adaptation of Lilo and
Stitch
apart from Toy Story Shrek is probably
one of the most iconic franchises in the
genre of 3D animation although the four
films about The Cult ogre have grossed
nearly 3 billion US dollars at the box
office it was quiet around the green
hero for a long time this is now
changing illumination CEO Chris
meladandri told variety that talks for
Shrek 5 are already ongoing although
melodandri's company is currently making
headlines primarily with the Super Mario
Brothers movie fans will be thrilled to
hear that he's devoting the same level
of enthusiasm to a Shrek sequel
according to his own statement he's
taking a similar approach to Mario
taking a close look at what the core
elements are that have made the
franchise so popular from there he says
it's hard work to integrate them into a
new story with more characters and
locations talks are currently being held
with the original cast including Mike
Myers as Shrek Cameron Diaz as Fiona and
Eddie Murphy as donkey all three are
absolutely delighted to be involved
again Murphy in particular previously
expressed his excitement about possible
Shrek sequels after the recent spin-off
Puss and Boots 2 The Last Wish was so
well received illumination CEO Melody
appropriately enough commented in the
same interview that donkey could
certainly benefit from a film of his own
as soon as we get new information about
the next Shrek movie we'll immediately
let you know
despite all the concerns The Game of
Thrones prequel House of the Dragon was
able to build on the success of the
original series so it makes perfect
sense that HBO is now considering
further spin-offs according to variety
another prequel series is currently
being planned around aegon Targaryen the
events surrounding the famous Dragon
Rider take place another 100 years prior
to the happenings of House of the Dragon
aegon set the foundation for the
Targaryen rule over Westeros and created
the Iron Throne thus a significant story
that is to be told in an epic series the
project is currently still at an early
stage at present the team is looking for
a suitable author to adapt the story to
a script however the series will not be
the only project HBO is currently
considering making a movie to introduce
the entire story we'll keep you posted
on how this project performs alongside
the numerous other Game of Thrones
projects that were announced in the past
and have already been partly scrapped
the next release will probably be House
of the Dragon season 2 sometime next
year
hardly any other topic is as hotly
debated among potterheads as the
adaptation of JK Rowling's Harry Potter
book series after the last appearances
of Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson and
Rupert Grint in the movie series Almost
12 years ago there is now news about a
reboot in a special format according to
various Hollywood media reports talks
are currently being held about an HBO
series based on the seven Harry Potter
books the idea is to produce a separate
season for each of the books this would
make it much easier to cover more of the
details of the original books which have
only been marginally touched upon in the
previous films or not at all this would
mean that seven seasons of the world
famous Harry Potter Saga would be
planned from the outset this is
naturally also associated with certain
risks especially if the series is not as
well received as anticipated actually
the idea has been circulating behind the
scenes for several years but it is said
to have been put on the back burner for
a while after the merging of Warner
Brothers and Discovery now that the deal
has been finalized last year however
production seems to be picking up pace
once again CEO David saslav has already
announced that he intends to make some
Harry Potter projects a top priority in
the future Creator JK Rowling is also
expected to play an important role in
the new projects and act as a producer
so far there is no official statement on
the Harry Potter series as soon as
further details come to light we will
let you know of course we are
particularly curious about the cast fans
will be Keen to know who will be
following in the footsteps of their
Movie heroes
in spite of its partly predictable plot
Avatar 2 the way of water was able to
impress fans and critics above all with
its visuals in particular the elaborate
depiction of marine life caused director
James Cameron to outperform his own film
Titanic on the list of the most
successful movies of all time as a
result he secured third place after the
first Avatar and Avengers end game
whether Avatar 3 can top the box office
takings which have now reached 2.24
billion US Dollars will be revealed next
year but before that there's an even
more significant question what will the
third part of James Cameron's successful
film series look like a first impression
is now provided by the latest concept
images as we already know Avatar 3 is
focused on new worlds following the
recent emphasis on the gigantic oceans
this time we can expect the exact
opposite with a Barren desert region
whereas the snow-covered landscape that
has been teased is likely to be
particularly cold and finally the
volcanic region shown here surely has a
special meaning is the home of these
so-called Ash people who will play a
major part in the upcoming film
alongside the previously introduced Navi
even though not a lot is visible of the
people yet the images of the three new
regions offer a first preview of what's
to come the new variety of Landscapes is
supposed to show that Pandora just like
Earth has many different peoples and
areas we are excited to learn more about
the Avatar 3 project in the coming weeks
and months the theatrical release is
scheduled for December 20th 2024.
Street Fighter is one of the most famous
gaming Brands ever and still Thrills
many gamers more than 30 years after its
original release the now announced plans
for a live-action Street Fighter movie
therefore caused quite a sensation among
fans but the idea has been there before
and many have rather disappointing
memories of it we are talking about the
1994 Street Fighter action flick
starring Jean-Claude Van Damme the movie
adaptation even made it to Time
magazine's list of the worst video game
adaptations of all time in 2009. since
then seven smaller films have been made
for the franchise but only the anime
Street Fighter 2 the animated movie
remains in memory in a halfway positive
way and that was also released in 1994
so it's evident that a new Street
Fighter live action movie won't cause
fans to jump for joy right away
nevertheless legendary entertainment
which recently enjoyed great success
with Dune and Godzilla vs Kong would
like to take up the challenge legendary
is said to have acquired the necessary
rights to the brand in order to to be
able to produce not only a live-action
film but also a series adaptation
likewise and bald is Street Fighter
Creator Capcom which will support the
upcoming projects at the moment there is
no specific information about when the
first film or series will be released
and above all which actors will be
involved before that Street Fighter 6
will be released on June 2nd the latest
part of the game series will certainly
provide a solid basis for further film
and series adaptations should it do well
there hasn't been a lot of Lilo and
Stitch movies since the mid-2000s now
there's finally going to be a follow-up
on Disney plus with a live action film
adaptation the story of the two odd
friends is world famous and it was
really only a matter of time before the
project which was announced back in 2018
would move forward the website night
Edge media exclusively announced at the
end of last week that the actress of the
young Lilo has been cast the actress
concerned is newcomer Maya kiloa who was
involved for the first time in such a
major project one aspect stands out
immediately she Bears an uncanny
resemblance to the cartoon character a
shitstorm due to miscasting as with
other Disney projects is therefore
unlikely the story of Lilo and Stitch is
about a young Hawaiian girl Lilo who one
day adopts a peculiar little creature
that resembles a dog it turns out that
this creature is an alien experiment
called 626 and is being sought by
Intergalactic Hunters the two embark on
a precarious adventure and together they
experience all kinds of bizarre
situations above all the charm of the
animated original is one of the reasons
why the franchise is so widely popular
it will therefore be exciting to find
out to what extent Disney manages to
achieve the desired cross between live
action and CGI besides Kia Loa hangover
star Zach Galifianakis was already cast
a long time ago however it is still
unknown which role the comedy star will
play by the way the script is the work
of Chris keca Neo Kalani bright who has
already received a great deal of Praise
as the author of 2016's Moana so far it
is not certain when Lilo and Stitch will
be available on Disney plus but we will
keep you posted as always
we hope you enjoyed the news which
particular project are you looking
forward to the most and if you haven't
had enough we highly suggest you to
check out the latest trailers for
Spider-Man across the spider-verse as
well as the new colorful Barbie trailer
thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you